نعود الى نعود الى جيفارا البديري في
حواره يبدو ان هناك تطورات
ما الذي يحدث جيفارا هل تسمعينني
لا نعرف ما الذي يحدث تفضلي
[تصفيق]
البث وصل هذا المستوطن الى هنا يحاول
تصوير الشبان جنود الاحتلال تحاول يحاولون
ابعاد
الفلسطينيين من هنا كما نرى نحن امام منزل
سكني العائله فقط تريد ان تحمي نفسها من
اعتداءات المستوطنين كما نرى على الهواء
مباشره لا يتم حمايه الفلسطينيين بل
ابعادهم ويتم تامين الطريق للمستوطنين
كل يوم رايحين جايين يلا روح
كما نرى حاله استفزاز حاله التوتر هذا
المشهد يعني نراه منذ يوم الاحد الماضي
على الهواء
هذا
المستوطن يقوم بشرط الاهالي كما يقوم بشتم
الصحفيين
هؤلاء من اشرس واكثر المستوطنين تطرفا
جاؤوا جاء بالطبع هو من مستوطنه
يسار على ما يبدو ولكن حتى اللحظه الوضع
هنا متوتر
الاحتلال واضح بان هناك الاهالي هناك قوه
من الشرطه او من الامن او من الجيش لا
نعرف بالضبط من الاسرائيليين
ما هو دورهم هنا
كما اذكر كما كما اقول لك الان هنا قوات
الاحتلال هذه القوه العسكريه كانت خلف
سياره المستوطن تحاول ان تؤمن له الطريق
على شارع حوار الذي هو اصلا محاصر بالكامل
كان هنا يتواجد بالصدفه لحظه وجودنا يعني
امامنا على الهواء لا نستطيع الا ان نؤكد
ما حدث امام اعيننا بان المستوطن نزل من
سيارته حاول استفزاز الاهالي الذين
يتواجدون امام منزلهم جنود الاحتلال الذين
يحمون سياره المستوطن قاموا بالنزول كما
نرى الان المشهد على الهواء قوات الاحتلال
تمنع الاهالي تقوم بابعادهم وتؤمن الطريق
فقط للمستوطن الذي يصر على عدم المغادره
بل هو برايي الاهالي يقوم باستفزاز
الاهالي المحاصرين منذ على احد الماضي
بالطبع هذه العائله منزلها تعرض الحرق
الكامل من قبل مستوطنيننا
يعني هذه العائله منذ الاحد الماضي تعرض
منزلها للحرب من قبل مستوطنين وحتى اليوم
لم يتم ترميم المنزل لان قوات الاحتلال
تفرض الحصار الكامل والشامل على بلده
حواره تمنع الطواقم الدفاع المدني السلطه
الفلسطينيه من الدخول الى هنا
لترميم هذه المنازل بعد المحرقه التي حتى
الاداره الامريكيه ولسان وعلى لسان بيان
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكد ان ما حدث هنا
بالمحرقه نستطيع ان نرى هذه المشاهد هنا
على الهواء مباشره تامين الطرقات بالكامل
للمستوطنين المستوطن هو من يتحكم بالميدان
قوات الاحتلال لا تقوم الا بابعاد
الفلسطينيين عن مواقعهم الان يبدو ان
المزيد من جنود الاحتلال يصلون الى هنا
تباعا ولكن هذا المشهد قد يختفي بعد ساعه
بسبب وجود عدسات الكاميرا ولكن مع ذلك
هناك يوم غد فقط شيء اخير يوم غد سيكون
هناك
المستوى يمثل كل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
التعرف اكثر الواقع هنا ربما سنتواصل معك
بالتاكيد في الفتره الاخباريه القادمه
اشكرك مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري من
بلده حواره